c'est par le biais d'un message vidéo
que svetlana tirs à 9 ce qu'aya a
interpellé ce vendredi le conseil des
droits de l'homme des nations unies la
situation en biélorussie exige une
attention immédiate de la part de la
communauté internationale des
manifestants pacifiques sont
illégalement détenus frappée et violée
nous la majorité démocratique de
biélorussie nous avons à plusieurs
reprises exprimé notre attachement à
l'état de droit aux valeurs
démocratiques et au dialogue pacifique
la requête de l'opposante en exil en
lituanie a été en partie entendue par
l'onu le projet d'un rapport sur la
situation en biélorussie a été votée à
genève une intervention devait être la
nature à neuf skieurs très critiqué lors
des débats par les représentants russes
et biélorusses aux nations unies elle
est contraire selon eux au règlement du
conseil des droits de l'homme
petite fille nîmois niasse il je
voudrais attirer votre attention et
l'attention de toutes les personnes
présentes ici 4 et sur le fait que le
format des déballeurs gens qui se
déroule aujourd'hui ne prévoit pas la
participation des noms représentant du
haut commissariat des nations unies aux
droits de l'homme
cher au commissaire adjoint des nations
unies aux droits de l'homme
sarni du rapporteur spécial ni de
personne d'autre
sauf les états prônée dassault n'a
pratiquement aucune manifestation ne
s'est déroulé conformément à la loi sur
l'organisation de rassemblements de
masse en l'occurrence nous ne parlons
pas de l'interdiction du droit de
manifester pacifiquement mais de la
procédure de sa mise en oeuvre
les participants violer la loi par
conséquent il ne visait une vague
d'arrestations dépit des déclarations
des opposants au gouvernement
les manifestations de la période du 9
août 11 août n'était pas toujours facile
chez l'émir nitrates l'opposante
biélorusse ne compte pas en rester là
puisqu'elle est attendu ce lundi à
bruxelles pour rencontrer les ministres
européens des affaires étrangères lieu
qui multiplie les condamnations travail
à une liste de sanctions contre
alexandre loukachenko et refuse de
reconnaître sa réélection du 9 août
dernier
de son côté le président biélorusse a
annoncé ce jeudi
la fermeture des frontières avec
certains pays voisins mon panier moi
même je t'avoue écoles chenal des sables
mais comprenons qu'il ne leur reste plus
beaucoup de possibilités dans leur
arsenal en dehors du lancement d'une
guerre chaude attesti nous sommes donc
obligés de retirer les troupes des rues
et de les déplacer de mettre l'armée en
état d'alerté de fermer la frontière du
pays à l'ouest
isaac lead que soderling grenier
principalement avec la lituanie et la
pologne
nous sommes obligés de renforcer notre
frontière renforcé la frontière avec et
notamment ses exercices militaires
menées vendredi dans la région de brest
non loin de la pologne des manoeuvres
conjointes de minsk et de moscou le
kremlin qui a réitéré ces derniers jours
son soutien à alexandre lukashenko et
condamné toute forme d'ingérence